giám ôn giấm khúc khi và thúc đầy ra thông xanh thì từ một một táng bệnh tới đây,
hà nội sẽ tý điểm bùng phát thải thấp tại khu vực hồ hành kiếm.
Các hi hoạch thì hà nội sẽ tý điểm vùng phát thải thấp tại khu vực lỗi hồ hành kiếm từ ngày bùng bùng tháng bệnh năm nay,
sau đó mở giọc theo lộ trình, một tiêu nhằm kiếm xuất khi thải, giảm ôn giữ khu khi và thúc đầy trên đổi sang các phương thức giáu thông thân tiện bú trường.
Các chuyên gia cho rằng là việc chiến khai cần tất trọc,
đồng bộ chính xác liệp bảo đầm tính khả thí và hiệu khoảng giải hát.
Các gia đoạn đầu thì phát vi tý điểm chủ hiệu kế thử ở không giang phố đi bộ hiện có
và mở giọc một số khu vực lần cận tại thông hành kiếm.
Sau đó thì bùng phát thấp dự kiến mở giọc giang toàn bộ hồ hồ vực chục tộc hành kiếm và mở giọc xanh các liệm bàn khác.
Dự kiến là trong ba cho đến năm năm tới, hà nội thì hương tới mở giọc phát vi đến phản đầy một,
và tiến tới vành này hai theo định vướng bú trình phủ.